Herkese
merhabalar ben Esra beyzadeoğlu
44 yaşındayım 12 yaşında bir oğlum var
Yaklaşık 22 yıldır aralıksız çalışan bir
iş insanıyım
Bugün her seferinde yeni bir şey
öğrendiğim ilham veren hikayeler in
paylaşıldığı bu platformda bulunmak
benim için çok büyük bir mutluluk ve
gurur kaynağı
oğluma bırakabileceğim bir
isps insanların onları diğerlerinden
farklılaştıran hikayelerini dinlemeyi
hep keyifli bulmuşumdur
dinlediklerim den öğrenmek Bazen hiç
fark etmediğim bu fark etmek ve günü
geldiğinde de Steve jobs'un söylediği
gibi noktaları birleştirmek Benim için
anlam yaratmak açısından çok çok
kıymetli
bu platform yaymaya değer fikirler ilham
verici kişiler dendiği zaman akla gelen
çok önemli bir platform
ilham verici bir hikayem var mı
bilmiyorum ama Tıpkı benim dinlediğim ve
esinlendiği gibi birilerine Esin kaynağı
olacak bir kaç nokta çıkar diye
düşünüyorum hikayemden
buraya davet edildiğim De sözleri Arda
arkasına nasıl sıralarım diye düşünmek
yerine ben en iyi neyi biliyorum diye
düşündüm Neyi anlatsam ahkam kesmeden
yapmacık durmadan samimi ve gerçek olur
diye düşündüm
ve bir zamanlar özgeçmişime yazdım ve
sonrasında da uluslararası alanlarda
kazan o ödüllerle çeşitli ödüllerle
sonrasında verdiğim röportajlarda
kullandığım cümle geldi aklıma bir tür
moto Toper petyum Mobile
İtalyanca Latince bir söz bitmeyen
enerji ve ilerleme demek
İngilizcesi never-ending enerji en
progres
bir şeyi bir yere yazınca O
neredeyse o andan itibaren kendini
gerçekleştirmek üzere harekete geçiyor
Sanki ben zaten enerji doluydum da mı o
cümleyi seçtim yoksa yazdım da ona mı
dönüştü Mina'nın Gerçekten bilmiyorum
Benim en iyi bildiğim şey çalışmak
sanırım sadece iş gibi düşünmeyin bunu
boğaz geçmeden çaba göstermek Gereken
neyse şikayet edip sızlanma dan değişime
ayak uydurarak korkmadan vazgeçme o gün
göstererek devam etmek Aslında çalışmak
bunu yaparken de çoğunlukla pozitif De
Kalmak bakın hep diyemiyorum Çünkü bazen
ben de düşüyorum kızıyorum Küfür
ediyorum yanılıyorum aldanıyorum ama
sonunda hep devam ediyorum
hayatın kaldırma gücü diyor Nil
Karaibrahimgil buna bayıldım biterim
oldu ben ilk okuduğum andan itibaren
biraz kendimden bahsetmek istiyorum ben
eğitimci bir ailenin iki çocuğundan
biriyim
95 senesinde İstanbul Atatürk Fen
Lisesi'nden mezun oldum mm senesinde de
Galatasaray Üniversitesi endüstri
mühendisliğini bitirdim
2013-2015 yılları arasında Sabancı
Üniversitesi'nde eksik etmeyin be
işletme yüksek lisans yaptım o hikaye
bitmedi
2019-2021 arasında da marka iletişimi
okudum O bu vazgeçilmez bir tutku gibi
ki şimdilerde bir üniversite yok devam
ettiğim ama sonrasını hiç bilmiyorum
yine olabilir farklı alanlarda bir şey
öğrenme hep açığı Çünkü
mezun olduğum mm senesinden beri İş
hayatın dayım 2007'den beri yönetici
seviyesinde farklı firmalarda çalıştım
2018'de de bu yöneticilik syllable
dediğimiz genel müdür yardımcılığı
seviyelerine çıktı o dönemden beri
barklı şirketlerde devam ediyoruz
yönettiğim alanlar geçmişten bugüne
baktığınızda bilgi teknolojileri siyah
RAM operasyon müşteri deneyimi insan
kaynakları gibi temelinde teknoloji ve
aslında insan olan çok sayıda konudan
sorumlu olmaktı yöneticilik alanındaki
deneyimi ve hala da deneyin biriktirmeye
bu alanda devam ediyorum
hep şanslı bir insan olduğunu
düşünmüşümdür bu yirmi iki yıllık iş
hayatımda Belkide en büyük şansım hep
Güzel insanlarla Yollarımı kesişmesi
oldu bazen bu güzel insanlarla ekipler
buldum bazen sıfırdan kurdum ve onlarla
birlikte gerçekten vazgeçmeden çalıştım
Bu sayede de ülkemizin dijital
dönüşümüne adeta şahitlik ederek için de
önemli bir oyuncu olarak rol alma
imkanım oldu bu bütün projeler binlerce
proje diyebileceğim seviyede proje
hayata geçerken
ekiplerimizle bir sürü de ödüle layık
görüldük
ödül deyince sadece ekiplerle değil bir
takım bireysel ödüller de kazandım Hep
de söylerim bireysel ödüller Aslında
arkada önemli takım çalışmalarının
sonucu birlikte yaptığımız işlerin
getirdiği başarıların bir tür
taçlandırılması
yine de burada birkaç tane önemlisin den
bahsetmek istedim Belki bu ilham verici
oy vereceğimiz veya Esin kaynağı
olabilecek hikayeyi bir parça daha
anlamlı kılabilir
bir 2015'te nesin deste ve Global bize
Wars da yılın teknoloji yöneticisi
kategorisinde tek kadın yönetici olarak
bronz madalya aldım
2016'da Global kadın Güçlendirme ve
liderlik zirvesinde yılın en iyi kadın
yönetici seçildim
sonrasında 2018'de Ailesi Türkiye
tarafından Türkiye'deki en iyi kadın
siyah Yo seçildim
2019'da Global
ödüller bir parça devam etti Londra
mensch Elif'in tekmagazin tarafından
gelecek vadeden on kadın teknoloji
vericisi arasına Türkiye'den giren tek
isim
oldum geliştirdikleri finansal
uygulamalarla teknoloji sektöründe
dijital dönüşüme yön veren ve en güçlü
kadın profesyonellerin açıklandığı kilo
bal Tab 100 fintech kadın yöneticisi
listesine de yine Türkiye'den giren tek
kadın yönetici olma şansının elde ettim
2020 senesinde de geri dönüp bakınca
epey ödül olmuş aslında ülkemiz için
birlikte çalıştığım insanlar ve kurumlar
için Bu ödüllerin ilham verici Işık
yakıcı bir umut olmasını umudum hep
başarının kutlanmaya değer bir şey
üretmenin insanı besleyen en önemli
kavram olduğunu yol üzerinde yürürken ve
büyürken gözlerimle gördüm şahit oldum
ve benimsedim
Bizi biz yapan şeyler aslında Zaten yol
üzerindeki Durak larımız oluyor biraz
aileden başlayan bir yolculukta bazen
taksitle bazen öğrenme lerle
şekilleniyor her şey Selam
bugün o yüzden size biraz da beni ben
yapan bazı kişilerden bu yolculukta ve
bazı olaylardan da bahsetmek istiyorum
Bunlardan biri de kendisi de çalışan bir
kadın olan emekli edebiyat öğretmeni
Annem
annem doğuştan kalça çıkıklığı bulunan
bunu tedavi etmek için dört yaşındayken
ayakları alçıya alınan aylarca alçıda
kalan ve 1950'li yıllarda bu konularda
her imkanın her yönüyle olmadığı bir
ortamda büyümüş kadın
Dedem Toprağı bol olsun yine de elinden
gelen her şeyi yapmış onu
iyileştirebilir Mac ve bütün bir insan
olarak hayata koşabilmek için
aynı rahatsızlık Anneannemde de olunca
annem hep ortopedisi olmak istemiş Gel
gör ki ki
ben onu Belki de dünyanın en anlayışlı
insanı olan Babamla aynı sınıfa yazmak
için İstanbul Üniversitesi Edebiyat
fakültesine göndermiş
Dedem annemi
1964 yılında gurbete ıspartadan
İstanbul'a edebiyat fakültesine tek
başına okumaya gönderen vizyonel bir
adam
ona millet içinde olan Annem teşekkürünü
Yıllar yıllar sonra Emekliliğine sadece
birkaç yıl kala yaptığı Master tezinin
önüne kızlık soyadıyla imza atarak yaptı
babasına ithaf ettiği tezinde baz
geçmeden devam eden bitmeyen enerjili
bir kadının teşekkürü yer aldı ğı
edebiyat profesörü olan Babam da sarıldı
anneme yolculuğunda Hep destek oldu
birlikte el ele durmadan devam ettiler
Evet
şimdi önünüzde Siz daha ilkokuldayken
40'lı yaşlarında Master yapan bir kadın
olunca sanırım çalışmamak Yılmak veya
Vazgeçmek çok mümkün değil
içinde ortopedist olup annesini
iyileştirme Tutkusu olan Annem ilkokula
başladığında abimin odasındaki aynanın
üzerine bir doktor amblemi Yapıştırmış
tı tamamen bilinçaltına bir mesajla
çalışma Belki de kader işte abim Şu anda
ülkemizin uluslararası alanda gurur
duyduğu son derece başarılı en iyi
ortopedi profesörlerinden bir tanesi
Evet ortopedi hatta öyleki yıllar sonra
annesinin çift taraflı kalça protezi
ameliyatına giren bir doktor kendisi
hayatın kaldırma gücü ile
önünüzde devam eden durmayan birileri
olunca
bu durmanız bekle mümkün değil
şimdilerde trend olan yaşam koçluğu var
biliyorsunuz annem bu kavramı Yıllar
yıllar önce daha hiç bu kavram ortada
yokken
çözmüş şimdi çok daha iyi anlıyorum
çevresine uygulamış bize de öğretmiş Biz
kendi modda larımızı perfetti Mobile
düşüncenize yaratmadan önce motorlarıyla
bize işlemiş birkaç tane örnek
anlatacağım size bir tanesine şöyle
diyor Mutlu yıllar yoktur mutlu anlar
vardır
briçte Size My full ız ız anda olmak
anın kıymetini bilmek ve mutlu olmak
üzerine daha güzel bir özet daha iyi bir
cümle olabilir mi
bir başka cümlesi şöyle öğüt verir veya
teselli ederken Boş durmak dertleri
yüzdürür çalışmak bu evet
hadi gel de tembellik et şimdi veya bir
şeyleri dert edip içinden çıkamam mümkün
mü 5 Kale bulur çalışırsan hiç bir dert
kasa kalmaz diye aklınızın köşesinde bir
yerlerde bir şeyler oluyor bir sözler
bir başka lafı sıkıcı ciddi işleri ancak
neşeli insanlar Başarır
bayıldığım bir söz Çünkü bazen ciddi
olmayı görev gibi gören doğallığını
kaybeden makamla ve değeri karıştıran
otorite kurmayı ciddiyet sanan ve neşeli
nice suçlu hisseden insanlar görüyorum
ve üzülüyorum Ne Yazık diyorum onlar
adına
2014'te 2016 senesi arasında o zamanlar
çalıştığım kurumda tiyatro kulübü
kurulmasına destek olup kendimde sürpriz
olarak o zaman Bölüm Başkanı olarak
çalışıyordum O 15 yıllık süreçte üç tane
oyunda tane de görev aldım rol aldım bir
tanesinde sahnede Tavukları Pişirmişem
söylüyorduk Hatta öyle bir oyun da son
derece eğlendim çalışmalar sırasında
öğrendiğim şeylerin en önemlisi sahnede
kendime güvenmek ve eğlenerek iş yapmak
üzerine oldu annemin bu lafıyla hep
cesaretlendirici ciddi işleri ancak
neşeli insanlar başarabilir bir
İlkokuldan itibaren
her sınavdaki bol bol sınavı geçti hayat
tahmin edebileceğiniz üzere Anadolu
lisesi fen lisesi o zamanlar üniversite
iki sınavdan oluşuyordu her sınavdan
önce Eğer beni annem endişeli gördüyse
söylediği bir söz vardı kesra seni
bayıltıp soksak bu sınavdan zaten iyi
alırsın
tam anlamıyla bir yaşam koçu yani
verdiği özgüvenle Bakın ben bu sınava
bayılıp girsem o zaten iyi bir not
alırım gel de bunun üzerine iyi not alma
daha iyisini yapmak için uğraşma
bir başka sözü
şiir Artı Matematik
eşittir dengeli insan Belki de bunun
etkisiyle işyerinde motivasyon
çalışmaları kapsamında Ben de içeriğini
Tamamen kendimi hazırladığı iki tane
seminer hazırladım bir tanesi şairler ve
aşkları bir diğeri Aşık ressamlar şiirle
çay ellerin ünlü ressamların
hayatlarıyla ve bu yolda ürettikleri
eserlerle Aslında aşkla bunu nasıl
beslediklerini anlatan iki güzel simleri
binden fazla insanın sundum açıkçası Fen
Lisesi mezunu bir mühendis için şiir
yanı ile denge gelmek hayatın
koşturmacası da ruhu beslemek için
Çabalar da bunların hepsi şiir Artı
Matematik eşittir o insan
annem bahsettiğim gibi bir kadın olarak
ilham veren destek olan bir rol model
oldu Hep
bununla birlikte kadın rol modellerin
sadece annemle kalmadı 22 yılda
yaşadığım hemen her iş değişikliğinde
etkileyici rol model başarılı güçlü
üretken bir kadınla yaptığım mülakat
Yolu şekillendirdi ve ne şanslıydım ki
her biriyle harika bir iş deneyim
yaşayıp her seferinde kendimi daha iyi
bir yerde buldum Belki de perpet yummo
bileli kadınlarla örülü bir yol inşa
ettim belki de kendime diyorum şimdi biz
işi yani Fani bedenle ama ölümsüz ruhu
canlıları biz yapan yolculuğu keyifli
kılmak Bu da hayatın Ben bunu denk Bence
yaşadığımız her olay bize şekil veren
yükselten ve hayatın her seferinde daha
iyi edilmesini sağlayan bir fırsat
şimdi 44 yaşındayım oğlum 12 yaşında Biz
bir yaşındayken babasıyla yollarımızı
ayırma kararı aldık hala ailelerimizin
istisnasız tüm Üyeleriyle her fırsatta
bir aradayız ve Oğlumuza iyi birer anne
ve baba olmaya çalışıyoruz
hayata öfke duyarak Neden ben diye
sorarak gelişme olmayacağını
bildiğimizden onun yerine evladımıza
Par'lı için her seferinde birbirimize
teşekkür ediyoruz böyle güzel bir çocuk
sahibi olduğumuz için
beni ben yapan yolda
oğlumun varlığı bir miktar hayatın
kaldırma gücü ile mı sizde eşleşiyor onu
kanatlarımın Altında ki rüzgar gibi
görüyorum Onun beni huzurlu umutlu
eğlenceli bir olarak tanıması için
çabalıyorum bunun tabi yapay olmaması
bir o kadar önemli çünkü mutlu değilken
mutluymuş gibi görünmek dünyanın en
yorucu işlerinden biridir diye
düşünüyorum önünde böyle enerjisi
bitmeyen Çalışkan üreten vazgeçmeyen bir
anne bir kadın rol model olarak beni
görmesini çok önemli buluyorum ben de
önümde böyle bir anneyle büyütün
Belki de bundan dolayı ben de kendi
annem gibi 40'lı yaşlara yaklaşırken
yaptığım Master da onun beni çalışırken
görmesini istedim ödevleri projeleri
yaparken oğlum 3 yaşındaydı bacağımdan
bilmiyordu neredeyse bütün çalışmalar
sırasında ve beş yaşına geldiğinde
diploma törenine birlikte gittik ve o
yaşta beş yaşında Öğretim Hayatına yeni
başlayan bir çocuk
geleceğin duyarlı bir erkek bireyi
annesinin kep giymesine ve diploma
diploma almasını tanıklık etti
ileride çalışan çaba gösteren enerji
dolu bir insan olmasının yanı sıra
kadına insana doğaya ve dünyaya saygı
duyan ve nezaket ile yaşayan biri
olmasın olmuyorum
her güne umutla başlayan çalışarak yeni
şeyler öğrenerek kendini ihmal etmeden
zenginleşerek adeta bir sincap merakıyla
kendini keşfeden dünyaya çevresini
keşfeden biri olduğumu düşünüyorum
dengeli bir insan şiirle beslenen
ruhu sürekli çalışan bu ve üreten bir
birey
ilham aldığım kadınlardan ilham
verebildiğin parçaları mla
bitip tükenmek bilmeyen enerji ve
motivasyonu mla Umarım bugün sizleri de
hikayeme bir parça ortak ede bilmişimdir
teşekkür ediyorum